these are the new fiti Hi-Fi dots and
we're going to compare them to the
airpods Pro 2 because fidi reached out
to us these are their high-end brand new
ANC earbuds that actually have three
drivers in each earbud which is gonna
make them sound very good we'll go ahead
and take a look now they also have some
very unique features that stand out so
let's go ahead and pop it out of this
box which is quite nice actually we have
some instructions up top and take a look
at that right there it looks like some
alien egg type smooth shape and what's
interesting wow okay that has some
weight to it what is interesting about
this case compared to a lot of the other
ones is that this is actually made out
of complete metal and I'm actually quite
surprised with how solid it feels
probably because of that metal design
feels like a little toy almost but
something very durable like a rock I
guess it does kind of look like a rock
now the way this opens unlike the air
pods which have this plastic little
cover it's magnetic this actually has a
button that you press bam it's like a
little switchblade and it has this metal
hinge if you guys could see that right
there multiple Parts with a spring let's
clip that on
I feel like people are just gonna sit
around and like play with this thing
that definitely feels like a nice fidget
kind of a toy but it has a very solid
clasp there so it's not just a little
magnet that holds it in and just like
the case the buds also don't only use
magnets but they actually snap in the
bottom as well to keep them secure and
for the charging mechanism unlike the
airpods which all use magnets to hold
the buds in place as well now outside of
the design these things actually have
very impressive specs of course you have
the triple driver design they also have
adaptive active noise cancellation and
they have lossless audio support because
they use a Snapdragon chip so if you
have an Android phone that supports it
which we're gonna test out you can can
get higher quality streaming audio that
matches CD audio so a much higher bit
rate than the air pods now the airpods
have that speaker in the case for the
find my tracking which is really nice to
have the Hi-Fi buds they're actually ipx
7 water resistant or waterproof instead
of ipx4 so the airpods they can get some
splashes or sweats while these ones are
actually completely waterproof so that
makes it more durable now our air pods
have a wireless charging built in and
then they have a lightning cable where
these have a USB type-c cable no
wireless charging because it is an
all-metal design that's very durable and
they give you a USB type-c cable and has
two different modes of fast charging so
you can charge everything up in about an
hour including the buds and the case
which is really nice and of course fast
charging for the buds as well now
comparing the earbuds themselves the
shape is very similar the Hi-Fi dots do
have a stem as well but it is shorter
than the one that is on the airpod pros
2 and as far as the weight uh the Hi-Fi
dots actually weigh less than the air
pods they really worked on keeping the
weight down while having that triple
driver design now I know the comfort of
the airpod pros too because I've worn
them a lot and it feels very similar to
air pods I don't feel the stem I don't
feel the butt itself it's very
lightweight and as far as design you
guys see it's not that just plain white
we have some different Design Elements
built in now as far as controls these do
use the more typical tap if you want to
pause unpause switch tracks or press and
hold if you want to switch between the
different modes whereas the air pods you
have that stem that you click and you
have that tactile kind of Click feeling
when you're switching between them now
as far as pairing with the air pods you
just pop it next to your iPhone right
now mine are connected so right here you
guys could see the battery percentage
now with the Hi-Fi dots we actually have
an app both for iOS and for Android and
these actually have a Multi-Device
support so you can actually have them
paired to two devices at one time and
switch between them so here let's go
ahead and hit add device and now we're
connected you guys see we have info
about the battery life our different
modes we have an ear plug test there we
also have an equalizer and you guys can
see you have a lot of adjustability
there we have controls where you can
change them and view all of them you
also have your manual and some other
settings and this little control panel
and lastly there is a lighting effect
that you can turn on with some different
options so if it even can you see that
on there yep yep I see it I see it so if
you want to show off your earbuds Now
you listen to music that is built in so
in this room we have a lot of HVAC noise
um from the furnace that's constantly on
here airpods Pros do a great job
right away that got rid of all of the
low end and I just hear a little bit of
the high end of the air coming through
that vent and these do a killer job even
on airplanes I stopped wanting to wear
my earpod Max and for the Hi-Fi dots I
have them in the mild noise reduction
which is set up so that if you don't
like a lot of pressure you won't feel
that but right now I could definitely
hear some of that low end noise still
being there not much of the high noise
let me switch it to strong here okay
that made a big difference
okay I gotta test this out
they say reduces like almost 50 decibels
of noise which is a lot it almost seems
like it does a better job
okay that was a noise cancellation mode
okay I I am having a hard time believing
this okay it actually does a better job
what
What I Hear less of the highs or almost
no highs and uh the low notes are just
as low as the airpods pro 2. that is
crazy and I actually hear less of my
voice especially the highs with these on
that is crazy and I'll switch it to the
transparency mode here airpods are
amazing in this all right everybody even
go ahead say something hey what's up
you sound fairly normal but some of the
highs are not as good as real life
so definitely better than a lot that
I've heard but I know that the airpods
are gonna do a great job in this
instance all right would you say
something now how do I say man now you
sound completely normal like in real
life and I think that could be because
of uh microphones or tuning so now let's
go ahead and do a microphone test this
is a microphone quality of Apple's
airpods Pro 2 and this is the microphone
quality of the Hi-Fi dots you guys let
me know which one sounded better down in
the comment section below and now let's
compare the sound quality this first
song is an EDM track
[Music]
to where we started
dang that video I was not expecting that
is it good it yeah that was really good
I mean they're triple drivers that makes
sense and the highs
they definitely stand out I might
actually go in the EQ good thing you
have it and turn it down a little bit
even though I do like sharp Highs but it
makes sense because you have three
drivers in there you have the separation
of the different frequencies but I was
not expecting to sound this good now
we're gonna switch to another track
before I listen with the loss list so
this is not lossless yet this one is a
rock track with a lot of instruments
I don't know
[Music]
my iPhone just told me to turn down the
audio
dang guys okay so three drives drivers
are better than one driver for sure I
mean you have the synth in there that
you guys heard that stands out probably
clear than I have heard uh in any other
earbuds the bass is good uh the mids are
great and it doesn't sound like
anything's really overpowering you guys
saw that neutral EQ of course you can go
in and tune that up there's a lot of
room to do that but it sounds nice and
natural but it still sounds good and I
think that's what really surprises me
with these earbuds along uh with the
active noise cancellation working that
well uh definitely better than I
expected out of the gecko I didn't think
they'd suck because these are not
inexpensive these are 200 bucks compared
to 250 MSRP but they do sound really
good and the last thing I want to test
here is with the nothing phone all right
we are all paired there and we do have
the Qualcomm aptx enable old and for
this last track I actually can't let you
guys listen to it because it is
copyrighted but here it is it is
lossless I'll take a listen to let you
guys know what I think all right guys so
listen to that track and this track even
though
um the Hi-Fi dots don't have spatialized
audio the song itself is very well made
so the airpods do have specialized audio
but here it just sounds incredible uh I
don't know how much that lossless is
helping streaming
um to them but the clarity is amazing
um having the triple drivers absolutely
does help and it's something that I hope
Apple does in the future because a lot
of brands are doing it and it's working
the triple drivers sound great so as far
as sound quality I'm very very impressed
now in terms of the battery life it is
actually rated identical six hours per
bud and 30 hours total for both of these
so there you guys go these are the
premium earbuds from fidi the Hi-Fi dots
and they definitely sound premium and
they feel premium if you guys want to
check them out use the link down in the
video description below go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those great videos
right over there the spin Max and I'll
see you in the next one
foreign